merci jean louis le seul merci gérard
mérigots les femmes du mlf réclame à
françois mitterrand une fête nationale
des femmes et pour elle seule elle
propose de la placer à la date du 8 mars
qui est un jour important dans
l'histoire des luttes des femmes une
fête fériée chômée et payée qui selon
elle ne fera pas double emploi avec le
1er mai une interview recueillie par
isabelle bélisle se reconnaissent dans
le premier mais quand elles sont aux
travailleuses professionnelle c'est à
dire qu'elles sont qu'elles ont un
travail rémunéré mais les femmes sont
aussi travailleuses en ce qu'elle a sur
le travail domestique qui est un
travailleur au noir et qui n'est pas
rémunéré et dans ce cas actuellement les
femmes ont produit en france en 1980
plus de huit cent mille enfants ce sont
deux notes de production qui ne sont pas
prises en compte par le 1er mai donc les
femmes sont travailleuses non seulement
à part entière mais trois fois le sombre
travailleuses à la puissance de 3 et
cette journée leur est due tout femme ce
bond le dira spontanément
si le gouvernement s'était montré
hostile à cette proposition
nous aurions demandé nous avions proposé
un ordre de grève générale des femmes
pour le 8 mars mais non seulement il ne
s'est pas montré aussi vous savez que le
président de la république à qui nous
avons écrit directement nous a fait
d'avoir une réponse dans les trois jours
ce qui est extrêmement bienveillant et
attendent ils de sa part avec un avis
très favorable
sympathique at il dit mais difficile la
difficulté nous le connaissons but ça
c'est pas ça qui va nous arrêter